- Don't you just love Christmas?
- Come on man, you don't actually believe
in Christmas do you?
Another round of shots please.
- No, not for me.
- Typical.
- Yo, what's your problem been man?
- You've abandoned me for some girl.
You couldn't walk a mile in my shoes.
- You think my shoes are just easy to walk
a mile in?
You and your stupid hat.
Merry Christmas.
(slow soothing music)
(gasps) I wish he only knew.
(swooshing sound)
(slow soothing music)
(screaming)
- I'm you.
- You're me.
- [Together] Did we just freaky Friday?
(screaming)
- Dude it's Christmas Eve.
I was supposed to meet Sandra's parents
for dinner tonight.
Now you have to go.
- Christmas doesn't exist.
I don't know anything about it.
- I'll help you.
- Fine.
(upbeat music)
- Do not mess this up, Justin.
- Zach relax, I got this.
- Check.
- Ah, yeah.
- Oh and there's one tiny
thing I forgot to mention.
Her dad is Santa Clause.
- Daddy this is Zach.
- Hello Mr. Clause.
- Sandra tells me you've
been having some problems
with your friend.
- Zach told you that?
- Of course you told me that.
You tell me everything.
- What else have I told you then?
- Finally alone.
- Don't you dare kiss her.
- Uh, what's that?
- Mistletoe, duh.
Why are you acting so weird?
- Excuse me we got some reindeer
illegally parked outside.
(laughs)
- Ryan.
- Ryan?
What the hell is Sandra's
ex boyfriend Ryan
doing in there?
- His family's spending
the holidays in Europe
so we invited him.
Hopefully he won't act as weird as you.
- Ryan loves Europe.
Why wouldn't he go with them?
This Christmas drink's pretty hot.
- More like chestnuts
roasting on an open fire.
(laughs)
- [Santa] Merry Christmas to all
and to all a goodnight.
What the bell?
(screaming)
- Santa (gasps).
Yo, Santa's been kidnapped.
- Justin?
- Zach?
I mean, Justin?
- Holy Hanukkah (screams).
- We have to save Santa.
- [Voiceover] We know where Santa is.
The building is going to be guarded.
- Hey.
(alarm sounding)
- Why are you putting us in so much danger
over a stupid made up holiday?
- Is this really about Christmas
or are you just jealous of me and Sandra?
- Unbelievable.
- I'm sorry I found
happiness and you're still
by yourself.
- I thought you were my best friend.
- Why don't you just grow up, Justin?
- Oh my God, Santa.
Who did this to you?
- Ho, ho, ho.
- Ryan why are you doing this?
- Whoever wears the fat bastard's hat
at midnight on Christmas
Eve becomes Santa.
That's why I'm doing it.
And that's why I dated Sandra.
- But I love her.
- You do?
- Yeah man.
- It looks like it's ho,
ho, hoes before bros.
(laughing)
(intense music)
- [Santa] You'll have to work together.
A great friendship is something you have
to fight for.
Never forget that.
(intense music)
Believe in each other.
Believe in Christmas.
- It's too late, Santa.
- [Santa] It's never too late Zach.
- How'd you know I'm Zach?
- He sees you when you're sleeping.
- You believe.
- I believe.
(upbeat music)
(screaming)
- I'm me again.
- (laughs) I believe this belongs to me.
(laughs)
- Santa, what are we
going to do with Ryan?
- [Santa] You leave
that little bitch to me.
(upbeat music)
Here comes Santa Clause.
♫ Come on, come on, come on
♫ Oh yeah
♫ Oh yeah, yeah, yeah ♫
- But I have to go, I have to pee.
- No, absolutely not.
I'm not going to have you look at my, no.
- Then what do you propose?
- Don't even think about looking at it.
- I'm not looking.
God, are you almost done?
- You have a way bigger bladder than I do.
(knocking)
(screaming)
(upbeat music)